Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, was ist eigentlich deine Lieblingsfarbe? Kadenabia-Blau.
Cadenabia Blau.
Meine ist Röhnendorf.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 470 vom 27.
September 2023 und hier seid ihr richtig bei den Leuten,
die noch zwischen blau und blau unterscheiden können, das kommt nämlich auf
die Nuancen an, ja das ist ganz wichtig, Farbtöne sind auch ein Teil der Wahrheit,
das muss man mal so festhalten, oder?
Ja, wofür steht eigentlich dein Cadenabia Blau?
Ja, das kann ich dir erklären, Tim. Hier Cadenabia Blau, eine Türkisfarbe, das.
Wollen wir in die Zukunft starten. So wollen wir die Zukunft gewinnen.
Oh Gott, Vitalität, die geht schon nicht mehr zusammen.
Ich hab's auch schon hundertmal gesehen und krieg's einfach nicht hin.
Da ist auch jede Eselsbrücke abhaken, da ist keine.
Das ist einfach nur so, ja CDU, Kardenabia Blau und Zukunft,
das ist einfach, das ist auch das erste, das erste woran ich denke ist aber echt an halt Türkis, ne?
Das Erste, woran ich bei der CDU denke, ist Freiheit.
Ja, Zukunft und Tückis und genauso wie bei der FPÖ.
Also, falls ihr uns nicht folgen könnt.
Aber das ist ja noch nicht das Peinlichste.
Nein, also die CDU hat sich ein neues Design verpassen lassen und ich finde
es bemerkenswert, dass der, wie heißt der, Lindemann?
Lindemann, genau.
Der Generalsekretär Lindemann. Mein Name ist Erwin Linnemann.
Ich bin Generalsekretär.
Und für mein Lottogewinn kaufe ich mir ein neues Blau bei meiner Lieblingswerbeagentur.
Genau und wenn ich groß bin, dann öffne ich eine neue Partei.
Also CDU macht jetzt auch auf Türkis. Sie haben gesehen, das läuft in Österreich ganz gut.
Und haben sich dann halt irgendwie zwei Blautöne irgendwie auf den Leib schneidern lassen.
Wir hörten es gerade. Karnabia Blau und Röhnendorf. Wofür steht das eigentlich,
Röhnendorf? Für Vitalität. Nein, ich meine, ist das jemand oder ist das irgendwo?
Wahrscheinlich ist da... Also Röhnendorf ist ein Stadtteil von Bad Honnef.
Ist das jetzt eine Vermutung oder eine gesicherte Aussage?
Achso. Ja, das stimmt. Aber was hat das irgendwie… ah, warte mal.
Oh, in den 1950er Jahren bekannt als Wohnsitz Konrad Adenauer.
Ja, ja.
Ach, herrje.
Da ist nämlich auch die Stiftung des Bundeskanzler Adenauerhaus und so weiter. In Bad Honnef.
Kadenabia ist in Georgien, der kleine,
in Italien, hätte auch Georgien sein können, man nimmt es ja auch nicht so genau,
dann haben sie dieses geile Image Video rausgehauen.
Schön ist auch, die haben sich so ein neues Logo verpasst, so ein schwarz-rot-gold-Logo,
auch sehr kreativ, mit so einem Schwung irgendwie drin, und der ist genauso
wie dieser Penisschwung von der AfD.
Der AfD hat doch so ein Dildo als Logo, und den kann man da jetzt direkt drauflegen
und das passt wunderbar.
Also das ist geil.
Georgien oder Italien, Hauptsache Röhnendorf. Dann haben wir noch den,
den, den, den, ach das ist so, da merkst du auch mal, wie hilflos die sind, ne?
Die müssen sich dann irgendjemanden kommen lassen, der denen dann irgendwie
ein Design macht und dann ihnen sagt, dass sie es haben.
Das machen ja alle, also ich meine, welche Firma ist schon in der Lage,
sich sowas selber auszudenken?
Ich weiß nicht, ne? Ich weiß nicht, wenn ich einen Imagefilm machen würde,
ne? Ja. Ob es mir passieren würde, also okay, ich sag mal, wenn ich einen Imagefilm
machen würde, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da der Reichstag drin vorkommt, gering.
Ja? Wieso eigentlich? Du bist doch da regelmäßig.
Aber wenn! Aber wenn?
Dann würde ich echt den Reichstag nehmen, also als Bild jetzt.
Also was ist passiert? Sie haben ein Image-Video rausgehauen,
wo sie irgendwie, ja hier geil, CDU, Deutschland und so, cool,
passt total zusammen und so und unser geiles Parlament.
Naja und dann haben sie halt irgendeinen Vogel bei irgendeiner Werbeagentur
davon damit beauftragt zu klimpernder Musik in irgendeiner Form dann die passenden
Bilder einzublenden und dann ist so kurz, hat der JPT gefragt.
Naja, ich meine so ähnlich wird es gelaufen sein. Wahrscheinlich wusste er nicht,
wie das Ding heißt, sondern hat nur Parlament mit Glaskuppel eingetippt und
das gibt's halt nicht nur in Deutschland.
Und dann kam halt irgendwie so ein View raus.
Und der Präsidentenpalast ist also ein Parlament mit einer Glaskuppel?
Naja, man muss das jetzt auch nicht so genau nehmen. Irgendwas mit Regierung und so.
Irgendwas mit Government halt. Glaskuppel passt schon irgendwie.
Auf jeden Fall kam dann der Präsidentenpalast in Georgien raus aus dem Stockfotoautomaten
und dann haben sie den halt rein montiert.
Wahrscheinlich einfach billiger. Und das geile ist, das fällt dann auch keinem auf.
Das ist das Ding.
Also dass es jemandem passiert, da habe ich, Verständnis ist vielleicht das
richtige Wort, aber das kann ich noch irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Weißt du, da hat jemand nicht nachgedacht, dann läuft das 30.000 mal über deinen Bildschirm,
dann achtest du gar nicht mehr drauf oder vielleicht war es auch irgendwie eine
alte Version und das ist schon mal gefixt worden, aber dann war die Person krank
und dann hat der andere das Backup vom letzten Tag genommen und dann war das
halt noch so und dann ist es keinem aufgefallen.
So, aber dann wird das dieser CDU präsentiert, aber bevor man das irgendwie
auf den Kanälen raushaut, schaut man sich das doch vielleicht mal an.
Oder? Aber wahrscheinlich sind die da nicht so oft im Parlament.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich so viel damit beschäftigt, sich bei irgendwelchen Lobbyorganisationen
irgendwie voll aufzulassen, dass sie einfach, ja ne, Reichstag war ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall lustig.
Schön für uns. Haben wir was zu lachen?
Haben wir was zu lachen. Ich meine, wir haben mit der CDU nicht oft was zu lachen.
Und vielleicht muss man einfach mal sagen, vielleicht sagen wir auch Danke CDU,
das war witzig, das hat Spaß gemacht mit euch. Warum nicht öfter so?
Warum nicht einfach mal öfter? Einfach auch mal selber ein bisschen nicht so ernst nehmen und ja.
Aber ich glaube, das machen die halt dann trotzdem noch schon.
Also die nehmen sich dann doch voll ernst.
Ja, die haben ja auch Erfolg damit gehabt. Sie sind ja jetzt in Georgien bei
41 Prozent mit ihrem neuen Image.
Cadenabia. Warst du schon mal in Cadenabia?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ist ein Ortsteil der Gemeinde Griante in Italien.
Liegt direkt am Westufer des Coma Sees und ist ein international bekannter Tourismusort.
Okay und da hat Adenauer gerne Urlaub gemacht oder … Pass auf,
wurde seit Konrad Adenauer verbrachtet zwischen 57 und 66 regelmäßig seit Urlaub in Kadenabia.
Sein ehemaliges Urlaubsdomizil, die 1899 erbaute Villa La Colina mit ihrem Park
von 5,7 Hektar, wird seit 1977
als internationale Tagungsstätte von der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung genutzt.
Ja, und da haben sie da genau die Kadenawia benannt, ok.
Also ist das alles Adenauer?
Ich dachte schon irgendwie der Duce hätte da irgendwas gegründet oder so, aber ja, ok.
Ne, Adenauer war ja auch noch ein strammer Antifaschist. Insofern ist ja schön, dass die...
Sorry ich höre auch auf,
die machen das nur damit wir was zu machen haben, damit wir auch unser Content
gefüllt bekommen, ich meine wir müssen ja hier auch die Minuten füllen,
wenn es nicht selber einfällt.
Tja ja, so ist es. Gut. Kommen wir zu Inhalten.
Ein bisschen Feedback kann man rumlegen noch? Ja, ähm...
Zur Störerhaftung. Oha, jetzt wird es detailliert.
Mark schreibt, zur Frage zum WLAN in Restaurants.
Also die Frage war ja, die wir uns auch gestellt haben, ist jetzt dieser neue
Entwurf, der auf EU-Ebene diskutiert wird, führt das quasi die Störerhaftung
wieder rein und sind Restaurants gefährdet.
Zur Frage zum WLAN-Ressort. In Artikel 2 Absatz A DSA,
also Digital Services Act, wird Dienst der Informationsgesellschaft als Dienst
im Sinne des Artikel 1 Absatz 1 B Bla Richtlinie sowieso definiert.
Dort wird Dienst als eine Dienstleistung der Informationsgesellschaft,
das heißt jeder in der Regel gegen Entgelt elektronisch im Fernabsatz und auf
individuellen Abruf eines Empfängers erbrachte Dienstleistung definiert,
also alles, was online ist.
Die weiteren Begriffe werden dort unter den weiteren Sätzen definiert.
Das ist nur mittelhilfreich.
In Artikel 3 Absatz G DSA wird übereinstimmend mit Artikel 4 Absatz 1 DSA der
Vermittlungsdienst definiert.
Danach ergibt sich aus der Formulierung Vermittlungsdienst eine der folgenden
Dienstleistungen der für Informationsgesellschaft?
Nämlich eine reine Durchleitung.
Demnach ist die reine Durchleitung immer auch ein Dienst der Informationsgesellschaft.
Damit sind wir wieder am Anfang. Was ist mit dem Restaurant?
Artikel 4 Absatz 1 DSA stellt aber weiterhin klar, dass der Dienst der Anbieter
nicht für die übermittelten Informationen haftet, sofern er die weiteren Voraussetzungen erfüllt.
Adressiert werden nach einer kurzen Durchsicht im Wesentlichen aber nur die Anbieter von Diensten.
Daraus würde ich vorbehaltlich der nur kurzen Durchsicht schließen,
dass das Restaurant entweder Anbieter des Vermittlungsdienstes ist und damit
von der Haftung befreit oder das Restaurant ist kein Anbieter und wird folglich
auch nicht von den weiteren Regelungen adressiert.
Wie gesagt, nur eine kurze Durchsicht, aber ich sehe da wenig Probleme für Restaurants. Okay, gut.
Und deswegen muss man Jura studieren.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Ich hab ja irgendwie Verständnis, Fäble soweit würde ich nicht gehen,
weil ich komischerweise, ich hab wirklich mit Rechtsformulierungen so meine Probleme.
Ich akzeptiere allerdings, dass die so einer inneren Logik folgen und die ist
halt extrem davon geprägt, dass man bestimmte Worte und Begriffe schnell auch als solche erkennt.
Also es gibt einfach so Schlüsselworte, von denen halt ein Jurist sofort weiß, dass es eins ist.
Dann wird ja zum Beispiel keins davon.
Ne das muss halt definiert werden, so allgemeine Worte definiert,
übereinstimmend, im weiteren Sinne, diese ganzen speziellen Verben,
die für uns eigentlich erstmal normale Worte sind, die aber im Juristendeutsch
eben eine konkrete Bedeutung haben.
Und damit eben so eine innere Logik in diesen Sätzen festmacht,
die sich natürlich dem Unkundigen, dem Rechtsunkundigen oder dem Juraunkundigen
nicht ohne weiteres und meistens auch gar nicht erschließt.
Ja insofern bin ich auch nochmal sehr gespannt wohin das geht so,
weil juristische Dinge vielleicht auch mal wirklich beweisbar zu machen,
ich weiß nicht ob das so wünschenswert ist aber das könnte nochmal so ein Thema
sein, was uns in Zukunft zu wünschen.
Also beweisbar meinst du formale Logik.
Ja, dass das sozusagen nachweisbar ist, dass irgendein Gesetz oder so,
aber das ist, ja, am Ende ist wahrscheinlich die Fuzziness in dem ganzen Kram
auch immer noch das einzige, was es mit der Realität verbindet.
Ja, und damit sind wir auch schon beim aktuellen Thema, ne? Die Chat-Kontrolle.
Und da zeigt sich jetzt wirklich dieser gesamte Themenbereich der Politik mal
so wirklich von seiner schönsten Seite.
Wir haben ja hier, also meinungsstark sind wir ja in diesem Podcast,
aber ich würde auch immer sagen, gleichzeitig faktentreu,
ja, natürlich machen wir auch mal Fehler in Interpretationen oder Schilderungen,
aber so insgesamt gehen wir davon aus, dass wir hier irgendwas erzählen,
was einen Realitätsbezug hat, ja. Und ähm...
Das ist uns auch wichtig, weil wir ja schon an den politischen Prozess irgendwie
noch glauben, in einer Form von, das ist leider der Beste, den wir haben.
Die Ergebnisse sind suboptimal, aber wir glauben schon insgesamt noch daran,
dass eine Diskussion, ein Austausch stattfindet.
Stattfindet. Wir wissen natürlich, dass die politischen Akteure getrieben sind
von allerlei Interessen und Abhängigkeiten, ne?
All das begleiten wir hier seit vielen Jahren. Aber so insgesamt glaubt man
ja denn schon noch irgendwie so restlich daran, dass das irgendwo hier mit halbwegs
mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Und dann hast du natürlich immer mal wieder so, natürlich ehrlich gesagt die ganze Zeit,
aber so Phänomene, die wirklich in dem,
wie sie so stattfinden, dir echt wenig Spaß machen und auch sehr geeignet sind,
den Glauben an dieses politische System zu verlieren,
was höchst gefährlich ist und was auch genau den Leuten,
die solche Dinge machen, eben auch anzulasten ist,
dass sie das politische,
demokratische System missbrauchen, nicht würdigen und einfach auch in Verruf
bringen als Akteure in diesem System.
Und ich glaube, bei der nun sich zuspitzenden Situation mit der Chat-Kontrolle
kann man das sehr schön sehen.
Und da komme ich auch an meine Grenzen,
zu sagen, puh, nee, nee, das ist schon in Ordnung und du solltest jetzt nicht
die AfD wählen, die sagt, das sind alles korrupte Schweine, weil das sind alles
korrupte Schweine, ja. Es ist schwierig.
Bei dem, was wir da jetzt so sehen, daran festzuhalten. Das so vorweggeschoben.
Zunächst einmal, in der letzten Sendung haben wir noch davon gesprochen,
dass sich eine Sperrminderheit im weitesten Sinne bei den Abstimmungen über
die Chatkontrolle im EU-Rat abzeichnet.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, super, das ist super, wenn die erreicht ist,
dann muss jetzt einfach Deutschland stabil bleiben und dann wird das zumindest
im Rat nicht ordentlich passieren, ja.
Was passiert, da sich das abzeichnet, bei dieser Abstimmung,
die unbedingt, ich glaube sogar morgen, am 28.09.
Stattfinden sollte, weil sich abzeichnet, dass sie nicht im Sinne der spanischen
Ratspräsidentschaft verläuft, verschieben sie halt die Abstimmung, ja?
Achso, wir sind uns ja noch gar nicht einig, wir sind uns ja noch gar nicht
einig über die Position,
die wir hier vertreten und wenn wir jetzt frühzeitig abstimmen,
dann riskieren wir den ganzen Quatsch, den wir uns hier überlegt haben,
dann können wir natürlich nicht abstimmen.
Weil es kann ja nur ein Ergebnis geben, nämlich dass es nicht so kommt, wie wir das wollten.
Können wir das nicht machen?
Wir haben... Geil.
Also... EU-Kommission macht dann Druck. Ja ihr diskutiert ja jetzt schon seit
fast 18 Monaten und das Gesetz muss jetzt beschlossen werden.
Die Kriminellen warten ja auch nicht. So wird irgendwie...
Haben sie gesagt wann, auf was das verschoben wird?
Warte, das wurde mir erklärt.
Ich glaube die nächste Sitzung ist dann am 14.
Oktober, also immer so ein grob vierzehntiger Rhythmus da drin und wenn da die
Wahrscheinlichkeit bleibt, dass es eine Sperrminorität gibt,
dann werden sie das einfach in den Dezember schieben.
Und dann wird das Gesetz aber quasi in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht mehr durchgehen.
Das heißt, da ist, also deswegen machen die natürlich auch so einen Druck und
versuchen irgendwie den Druck auszuüben, dass jetzt eine Entscheidung stattfindet.
Aber so, du kannst dir natürlich auch vorstellen, dass die in Anführungszeichen
Gegenseite genau weiß, wie sie damit umgeht.
Und dass sie natürlich jetzt den Druck erhöht und deswegen kommen ja diese Sätze,
wie die gerade zitierten, ja ey, ihr müsst mal endlich in die Potte kommen,
ihr diskutiert ja seit 18 Monaten, jetzt müsst ihr mal endlich euer Ei legen und so,
ne, einfach mal zu überlegen, ja ne, vielleicht wären wir uns hier auch einfach
nicht einig, vielleicht war eine Scheißidee, gut, dass wir 18 Monate darüber
diskutiert haben, bis wir es alle eingesehen haben und jetzt machen wir es mal nicht, ja.
Aber da werden die natürlich nicht hinkommen.
Gut ich meine das ist so ein wichtiges Projekt, was jetzt im Mittelpunkt einer
Ratspräsidentschaft steht.
Also die Ratspräsidentschaft, also wer es nicht so auf dem Zeiger hat,
das ist ja sozusagen so ein durchrotierender Job, da kommt jedes Land mal dran,
immer für ein halbes Jahr.
Und man nimmt sich dann ja in der Regel immer irgendwas vor und es gibt natürlich
auch eine Erwartungshaltung an eine Ratspräsidentschaft.
Nämlich, dass sie effizient ist, dass sie die Dinge voranbringt etc. pp.
Und typischerweise treten solche Ratspräsidentschaften ja dann auch immer mit
irgendeiner Agenda an und sagen so, hier das sind für uns jetzt die wichtigen
Themen, das wollen wir jetzt hier aber auch fertig machen und das kriegen wir
schon auch irgendwie hin.
Und dann ist das natürlich auch so eine Sache, da fühlen die sich dann wahrscheinlich
auch so in ihrer Ehre gepackt.
Das ist sozusagen ein No-Go, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, dass man dann eben so
ein Highlight, was man herausgestellt hat, so ja da wollen wir uns jetzt drum
kümmern, das ist uns wichtig, das werden wir jetzt hier irgendwie voranbringen,
dass das dann jetzt sozusagen gar nicht abgestimmt wird.
Und wenn jetzt quasi deine Sperr-Minorität sich hält und sich dann auch in einer
finalen Abstimmung durchsetzen würde, dann wäre das Ergebnis ja salopp formuliert
EU versagt bei Kinderschutz.
Und den Schuh will sich ja keiner, keiner will den haben.
Müssten sich natürlich jetzt einigen.
Ja, aber da liegen leider die Vorstellungen ein bisschen weit auseinander und
da ist halt auch der gesellschaftliche Widerstand dann doch irgendwie zu groß,
weil ihnen dann irgendwie doch aufgefallen ist, dass das so vielleicht nicht
der geilste Ansatz war und so recht Alternativen haben sie aber auch nicht.
Sie haben sich jetzt sehr festgefahren in diesem einen Ansatz und der wird jetzt
irgendwie durchgekämpft.
So, jetzt haben wir weiterhin, aber das ist ja noch nicht alles,
dass es irgendwie Geschäftsordnungstricks im weitesten Sinne gibt,
um da irgendwie ein frühreifes Abstimmungsergebnis zu riskieren,
das ist ja noch okay oder sagen wir das schockiert jetzt niemanden mehr,
was sehr irre ist, ist die.
Auseinandernehmung des Lobby-Geflechts in diesem Kontext.
Und das ist wirklich irre,
weil es eine ausführliche, also wirklich riesige Recherchen gibt,
die so umfassend sind und so viele Interessenkonflikte und Verflechtungen und
sonstiges aufzeigen, dass wir in der Sendungsvorbereitung festgestellt haben,
dass wir das nicht vollständig zusammengefasst schaffen.
Wir schaffen es nicht, das vollständig zusammenzufassen. Aber immerhin so mal
die wichtigsten Highlights aus einer Recherche,
die von einer Seite namens Balkan Insight veröffentlicht wurden,
Allerdings auch von Zeit Online und weiteren europäischen Medien,
also eine ausführliche Recherche von einer Zusammenschluss an europäischen Journalistinnen,
die sich damit auseinandergesetzt haben, wie das eigentlich so zustande kommt.
Und die Geschichte beginnt ...
2012 damit, dass die Kinderschutzorganisation Thorn gegründet wird und dass
da irgendwie Ashton Kutscher und Demi Moore mit an Bord sind.
Ist ja auch klar, wenn du dann irgendwie so ein Star bist, dann musst du irgendwie,
Ja, muss aber ein bisschen was Gutes tun, ne? Für deine eigene Marke und so,
ne? Das gehört sich so und Kinderschutz bietet sich da irgendwie an.
Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete. Also wir hatten das Thema ja hier auch schon
mal aufgegriffen mit Herrn Kutscher.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und man denkt ja immer der Kutscher kennt den Weg, aber hier sind wir uns nicht so sicher.
Und diese Organisation Thorn, die gibt es so vor sich hin und man denkt,
ne Kinderschutzorganisation ist es ja auch.
Die hat aber ein Side-Business, nämlich, dass sie eine AI herstellt und vertreibt,
die diese CSAM-Detektion macht.
Also, du bist so eine Kinderschutzorganisation und damit das auch wirklich vorangeht,
hast du direkt auch noch das Produkt dafür, ja.
Dieses Produkt bietest du natürlich irgendwie allen möglichen Leuten zum Kauf an.
Zum Beispiel dem US Department of Homeland Security, was, also nur das US Department
of Homeland Security hat Software Lizenzen für 4,3 Millionen US-Dollar von Thorn, ja.
Das ist nur einer der Kunden. Andere Kunden sind Vimeo, Flickr und OpenAI.
Und ich glaube, da kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass man mit diesen großen Unternehmen,
die sicherlich auch sehr viel mehr scannen müssen und ein Business Case dahinter
haben, dass man bei denen vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Geld bekommt als beim
US Department of Homeland Security.
Und diese Organisation THORN schreibt die Ilva Johansson an dem Tag,
wo sie ihr Proposal vorstellt, ja.
Wir erinnern uns, das muss dann jetzt ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre her sein,
dass sie gesagt hat, hier schaut mal her, ich habe einen Vorschlag.
Ich als Kommissarin gehe jetzt hier hin und schlage etwas vor.
Und wir wissen auch, dass diesem Proposal ja noch mehrere Jahre anderes Theater
voranging, nämlich dass sie diese E-Privacy-Richtlinie abgeschwächt haben und so.
Also das ist so richtig von langer Hand geplant.
Jedenfalls an dem Tag, an dem sie dieses Proposal vorstellt,
schreibt Eva Johansen an die Executive Director von Thorn, Julie Cordua.
Wir haben viele Momente gemeinsam erlebt auf der Reise zu diesem Proposal.
Jetzt blicke ich auf euch und hoffe, dass ihr dafür sorgt, dass es auch ein
erfolgreicher Launch ist.
Ja, das schreibt die EU-Kommissarin an die Leute, die am Ende mit dem Quatsch Geld verdienen wollen.
Das ist ja schon, ehrlich gesagt, ein absoluter Irrsinn.
Ich finde das ja in Ordnung, wenn die sich jetzt mit einer Kinderschutzorganisation,
die klar keine eigenen kommerziellen Interessen verfolgt,
zusammentun würde und sagt, ich hab
das mit euch mal entwickelt und jetzt unterstützen wir dich bitte auch.
Ich hab mich hier sehr für euch eingesetzt. Aber das ist ein Unternehmen mit Millionen Umsätzen,
das politisch agiert und im Prinzip eine Legislation haben möchte,
die dafür sorgt, dass das Produkt verpflichtend wird, was sie haben.
Finde ich irre. Dann gibt es irgendwie, dann ist da diese Eva Kiley,
das ist diese Griechin mit den Geldsäcken, die Altitüden mit den Geldscheinen da.
Die hat dann da irgendwie ein Event, wo dann Kutscher und Johansen rumrennen.
Und was du aber nicht herausfindest ist, wenn du nach einem Freedom of Information
Act die Kommission fragst und sagst,
ja, hör mal, es gibt da so E-Mails von der Frau Cordua,
also der Executive Directorin von THORN, mit denen sie geantwortet hat auf die
E-Mails von Ilva Johansson, zum Beispiel auch mit einem Policy One Pager.
Und wir würden das gerne mal sehen, was Thorn euch da geschickt hat,
als Policy One Pager, liebe EU-Kommission.
Und dann sagen die, ja ne, das können wir nicht machen,
wir können euch nicht sagen, welche Policy One Pager uns dieses Unternehmen
geschickt hat, Weil wenn wir das veröffentlichen würden, könnte das die kommerziellen
Interessen von dieser Organisation verletzen.
Die kommerziellen Interessen.
Geil. Wofür haben wir denn Freedom of Information,
damit die irgendwie Policy One Pager an unsere EU-Kommissare schicken und wenn
wir sagen können wir mal sehen was die euch vorgeschlagen haben,
nur um mal so einen kleinen Lobby Plug Vergleich zu machen.
Um mal zu gucken, wie viel ihr da abgeschrieben habt. Ja, nee,
das wäre ja jetzt dagegen deren wirtschaftlichen Interessen.
Wenn ihr wisst, was die uns schreiben. Irre, oder?
Das ist echt eine Frechheit.
Und das sind nur so die Schmankerl, die besonderen Größe aus der Küche.
Dann gibt es die We Protect Global Alliance. Auch das hätte ich niemals gedacht.
Also, das sind zwei zusammengeführte Organisationen.
Die eine wurde von der EU-Kommission und den USA gegründet, die andere von Britannien.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ja voll geil, lass uns mal irgendwie,
wenn wir beide das gleiche machen wollen, dann lass uns doch die We Protect
Global Alliance sein und dann machen wir einfach unseren Sitz jetzt in Holland.
Okay, irgendwo an der Nordseeküste, so. Und diese We Protect Global Alliance,
die eigentlich von Regierungen ins Leben gerufen wurde,
rennt da jetzt irgendwie rum, hat Board-Meetings, kriegt Spenden,
lobbyiert für diese Thorn und hat außerdem
im Board einen Mitarbeiter der EU-Kommission und nicht irgendeinen,
sondern Antonio Labrador Jiménez, der das CISEM-Team der Kommission,
also quasi diese gesamte Initiative von Ilva Johansson leitet.
Der ist zwar erst seit Juli 2020 im Bord, aber in den Bordmeetings vorher,
2019 und so ist er auch schon anwesend. Auch geil, ne?
Hast du eine Organisation mit einem Bord und der, derjenige,
der irgendwann ein Jahr später ins Bord kommt, der arbeitet bei der EU-Kommission
und ist schon mal vorher bei den Meetings. Was ist da los?
Kurze Wege auf jeden Fall.
Das sind wirklich kurze Wege und irgendwie,
natürlich zahlen die dann auch noch alle die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Millionenbeträge
an irgendwelche PR-Firmen,
ja, und das wundert einen jetzt auch nicht,
was dann da an Geld rumfliegt, außer dass dann die Oak Foundation irgendwie
24 Millionen US-Dollar an Organisationen wie Thorn,
oder EC-PET für Lobbying gesteckt hat.
Die haben ein Lobbying-Budget von 24 Millionen US-Dollar, allein nur von dieser
Org-Foundation seit 2019.
Und Thorn ist ein gewinnstrebendes wirtschaftliches Unternehmen.
Das ist irgendwie alles so völlig unklar.
Wenn mir das, wenn, wenn das jetzt nicht von seriösen Medien geschrieben worden
wäre, würde ich sagen, alter, hast du das aus irgendeiner Telegram-Gruppe oder so?
Vor allem das sind wirklich bemerkenswerte Beträge, die im wesentlichen alle
nur fürs Lobbying drauf gehen.
Und es gibt ja irgendwie ein Zoo von, also in diesem Artikel sind ja dann auch
irgendwann kommt so eine Stelle, wo dann wirklich so eine europäische Kinderschutzorganisation
nach der anderen genannt wird.
Und ich finde es schon bemerkenswert, wie denen eigentlich immer noch ein neuer
Titel einfällt, um eigentlich immer wieder genau dasselbe zu sagen.
Nämlich wir tun irgendwas für Kinder, aber unsere Kohle geben wir eigentlich
hier nur für Politlobbyismus aus.
Aber es gibt halt ohne Ende solche Organisationen und es ist ein bisschen unklar
was die machen und das ganze Geld, was sie da investieren, das ist halt eigentlich
immer alles nur auf Gesetzgebung.
Das ist jetzt eine Vermutung von mir, muss ich zugeben. Ich habe mir jetzt die
Programme nicht im Detail angeschaut,
aber diese Gelder, die sich da auf Lobbyismus werfen,
wenn sie das auf konkrete Kinderschutzprogramme werfen würden,
die also wirklich, sagen wir mal, Kindern zugutekommen, also konkret Kindern
zugutekommen, nicht irgendwie indirekt und im Prinzip, dann wäre vielleicht
auch schon mal eine ganze Menge erreicht.
Aber das ist hier nicht so richtig das Ziel.
Nee, das ist, hier Thorn,
ein gewinnstrebendes Unternehmen, ja, hat irgendwie 5,25 Millionen US-Dollar
von dieser Oak Foundation bekommen,
die We Protect Global Alliance nochmal irgendwie 2,3,
ja, das sind nur die, und du fragst dich, also die nennen sich dann immer Kinderschutzorganisationen
und wenn du sagst so, sag mal, was macht ihr, um die Kinder zu schützen?
Erzählt mal, was ist denn so euer täglicher Beitrag?
Ja, wir nehmen im Prinzip das Geld und dann geben wir das irgendwelchen PR-Unternehmen
oder Lobbyisten von Capgemini und die gehen ins EU-Parlament und beziezen da
die Kommissarinnen oder die Parlamentarier und sorgen dafür,
dass Gesetze umgesetzt werden, die am Ende Geschäftsmodell für die Organisationen
sind, für die wir Geld geben.
Also völlig irre, oder?
Ja, also man darf hier natürlich jetzt nicht Unrecht tun. Sie organisieren ja auch Konferenzen.
Ja, genau. Organisieren auch Konferenzen, wo sie dann mit den Leuten Schnittchen
essen. Irgendwo muss sie ja kennenlernen.
Dann außerdem steht natürlich, dass die Ausweitung von diesen Technologien sofort
auch schon auf der Liste steht.
Im Juli 2022 kommen Europol-Vertreter mit dazu, die dann schon sagen,
ja, es gibt ja auch andere Kriminalitätsbereiche, die von KI-gestützter Erkennung profitieren würden.
Wollen wir ja nicht nur für Missbrauchsbilder.
Ja, das ist, äh, es ist wirklich, ähm, ja, sehr, sehr ernüchternd, ne.
Ja also die Liste ist wirklich lang, also es gibt unter anderem eine European
Child Sexual Abuse Legislation Advocacy Group,
EC-LAC, wo dann andere Kinderrechtsorganisationen wie EC-PART,
Euro Child, Missing Children Europe, die Internet Watch Foundation,
Terre des Hommes und noch diverse andere Mitglied sind und am laufenden Meter
werden hier weitere Organisationen genannt, das Brave Movement.
Dass dann wieder Geld von der oak foundation gibt für together for girls und so weiter also es ist,
ja ich will das jetzt nicht alles über einen Kamm scheren das ist halt und das
hast du eingangs finde ich gut gesagt man ist halt davon dann auch schon Die
Komplexität die das hier sozusagen,
ich hab das Gefühl wir zählen die Beteiligungsgesellschaften von von Bergman
Heatherway irgendwie auf.
Heatherway so ja Warren Buffets Aktienimperium, weil irgendwie alle mit allen
irgendwie reden so aber um zurückzukommen auf diesen Artikel der bei Balkan
unsight erschienen ist und der das halt hier lange auflistet.
Es wird hier relativ klar, dass es hier ein Hand in Hand gibt zwischen der Kommission
oder bestimmten Kommissionsmitgliedern und diesen Organisationen und dass die
halt gemeinsam da an der Legislative feilen,
die sie eben jetzt gedenken umzusetzen.
Und das wäre ja noch nicht mal schlimm, wenn das Organisationen wären,
die aus irgendeiner, wie du schon gerade sagtest, die einen Kontext ihrer Arbeit hätten.
Natürlich würdest du ein Gesetz machen, was die Arbeit von Ehrenamtlichen oder
auch von mir aus beruflichen Katastrophenhelferinnen betrifft.
Ja dann natürlich redest du da mit dem deutschen roten Kreuz oder mit was weiß
ich, mit Cadus oder wem auch immer.
Ja aber die haben da keine finanziellen Interessen in diesem Spiel,
keine dass sie da Produkte für einen Markt anbieten.
Keine dass ihr Produkt alternativlos zwangsverpflichtend für den kompletten
europäischen Markt wird. Genau.
Also ja wir müssen jetzt hier Nothilfe in Flüchtlingsregionen machen aber die
Autos die dürfen nur wir bauen.
Also das ist ja und dann auch noch irgendwie Organisation und Kommissionsmitarbeit da in Personalunion.
Was ist das denn?
Ja, das ist auch strange.
Also das ist, ja, das ist wirklich fies und das macht wirklich wenig Spaß das zu sehen,
weil, ja, irgendein Hollywoodstar, der dann da rumrennt, weißt du,
den sie dann da hin und her schicken.
Übrigens, ich glaube, wir hatten das gar nicht erzählt, der Ashton Kutscher,
der stand ja dann in der Kritik, weil er sich für seinen Vergewaltiger,
für seinen Freund, der mehrfacher Vergewaltigung oder sowas war,
das ja, verurteilt wurde, weil er sich ja noch dafür eingesetzt hat,
dass der eine geringere Strafe bekommt, da haben sie dann festgestellt,
dass das potenziell nicht so den Zielen der Organisation gerade nicht so hilft.
Er ist ja jetzt zurückgetreten.
Ja, feine Leute. Da lobe ich mir so eine richtig schöne, ja nee,
das ist ja die Wirtschaft, die das unterbehandelt.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mir da noch lobe, aber es ist wirklich, zumindest erklärt,
verstehst du dann halt irgendwie so Jahre später, die so ein Thema behandelt
und du denkst so, warum ist denn diese Idee, die so verrückt und so gefährlich ist,
nicht tot zu kriegen und dann weißt du halt ja die haben ein paar millionen
euro da reingekippt und einfach breitbrüstig da irgendwie ihre argumente vorgetragen.
Den grad an finanzierung würde man sich für die netzpolitik manchmal wünschen.
Ja könnt ihr uns gerne spenden habe ich überhaupt nichts gegen.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal bei der Oak Foundation bewerben.
Kennst du die Org Foundation?
Das sind halt auch alles solche Organisationen von irgendwelchen reichen Leuten,
die dann Gutes tun wollen in Anführungsstrichen und dann halt irgendwie Kohle
an andere Organisationen weitergeben.
Wo ja auch erstmal nichts dagegen zu sagen wäre, da gibt's ja auch gute Beispiele,
wenn man sich mal so Soros Foundation und sowas anschaut, aber es gibt halt
da einfach ein schwer durchschaubares Geflecht an Interessen.
Aber genau deswegen machen wir Dinge, über die wir nachdenken.
Jetzt machen wir mal eine Frage. Schauen wir mal, was die Oak Foundation sonst
noch so an Programmen hat. Ich hab mal den CSAM-Programm verlinkt.
Kinder, die lebenslange Gefängnisstrafen erwarten, um die sie sich kümmern.
Dann Unterstützung des California Age Appropriate Design Code Act.
Dann in Moldo- äh Moldawien gleiche Rechte für Männer und Frauen.
Kinder, die Kriege überlebt haben, die dann irgendwie sportliche Leistungen
unterstützt bekommen werden.
Traumasensitivität in Schulen für Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, ein Regenbogen für
die Hilfe bei Kindern, die einen Krebs überkommen.
Das sind alles Projekte, die
jetzt deswegen 24 Millionen insgesamt weniger bekommen haben, ne? Bitter.
Ja, vielleicht haben wir noch genug, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so schlimm.
Tja, also, gut, wir haben es, wir haben es, äh, wir haben unserer Ernüchterung
Raum gegeben und, ähm, ja, entweder Mitte Oktober oder Mitte Dezember wird dann
eine Abstimmung stattfinden.
Das heißt, diese heiße Phase bleibt und wir können hoffen,
dass Spanien weiterhin es nicht gelingt, die anderen weich zu kochen und den
Druck auszuüben und ich bin mir sicher,
dass die sich da inzwischen nur noch gegenseitig bedrohen, wie sie das framen,
wenn die Sache schief geht.
Mal schauen, ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass es schief gehen wird,
eben aus den genannten Gründen, dass es nicht schief gehen kann.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in einer politischen Auseinandersetzung dann
die harten Bandagen ausgepackt werden und dann auch so die Trades gemacht werden. Wenn ihr dafür stimmt.
Dann lassen wir ja auch hier das, was bei uns eigentlich gar nicht geht,
das lassen wir dann auch durch, weil das wollen wir jetzt hier unbedingt haben.
Und dann ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen die Frage, was,
ist eigentlich so ein politischer Erfolg am Ende wert? Also was verspricht man sich da eigentlich?
Geht es dann eigentlich.
Nur noch um persönlichen Erfolg der Leute, die das so durchfechten,
also der KommissarInnen oder der Fraktionen, die dahinter stehen?
Kinderbelästigungsschiene einfach auch immer wieder diesen Input bekommen wird,
um Gesetze weiter zu verschärfen.
Selbst wenn eigentlich relativ klar ist, dass diese beschlossenen Gesetze am
Ende diesen deklarierten Erfolg so gar nicht bringen.
Dass dadurch nichts wirklich besser wird.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Einfach nur der Freiheitsaspekt muss dann am Ende drunter leiden.
Da hat man dann einfach nicht das richtige Blau genommen dann auch.
Noch eine schlechte, halbwegs gute Nachricht, ne eigentlich nicht,
aber noch eine die keinen Spaß macht, ne?
In Ägypten, ja hallo, komm zu unserem scheiß Podcast, hier haben wir noch eine
scheiß Nachricht für euch, gute Nacht.
Der Ahmed El-Tantawi, ehemaliger ägyptischer Ministerpräsident,
hat bekannt gegeben, dass er gerne Präsident werden würde 2024 und kurz darauf
wurde sein Telefon infiziert mit der Schadsoftware Predator des Herstellers Citrox.
Das ist die Schadsoftware, die in Griechenland im Trojaner-Skandal so eine große
Rolle gespielt hat. Ungefähr vor einem Jahr haben wir auch glaube ich damals behandelt.
Dort gab es das auf dem Telefon von griechischen Journalisten und ähnlichem.
Hat da eine veritable Krise.
Ausgelöst dieses Citrox ist in den USA mit Sanktionen versehen und irgendwie
ein relativ unklares Unternehmen,
was in Nordmazedonien glaub ich ursprünglich gegründet wurde und dann irgendwie
unklar sich weiter verhalten hat,
gibt es wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie da, also kommt irgendwie aus Europa ursprünglich
zumindest, findet relativ wenig über dieses Unternehmen.
Warum ist das eine interessante Nachricht? Naja, kommt offenbar aus hiesigen
Breitengraden und wurde,
diese Infektion wurde vom Citizen Lab detektiert und hat mal wieder drei CVEs auf dem iPhone.
Also Common Vulnerabilities and Exposures, also offiziell dokumentierte Schwachstellen
auf iPhones zufolge gehabt, die in aktuellen Versionen 16.6.1,
und ich denke dann in der 17.0, die jetzt wahrscheinlich rauskam,
gerade auch behoben wurden.
16.7 und 17.0.1. Okay und ja.
Völlig normale Nachricht, dass wenn da jemand Ambitionen hat,
gewählt zu werden, dass die amtierende Regierung den natürlich sofort erstmal
mit ihrer Spionagesoftware hackt, ist halt irgendwie offenbar relativ normal.
Wo kommen wir denn da auch hin, dass Leute sich legitim in einem demokratischen
Prozess hier um Macht bewerben?
Vielleicht wurde die CDU ja auch gehackt, deswegen haben die den georgischen
Präsidentenpalast in ihrem Video gehabt. Vielleicht war das ja so.
Steile These. Naja, ein Software-Update könnte die CDU auf jeden Fall mal gebrauchen.
Aber ich glaube da ist schon länger keins rausgekommen.
Röhnendorf und Cadenabia, ihr merkt schon wir sind schon im Epilog angekommen,
ja ist doch auch mal schön wenn es nix neues gibt,
Gute Nachrichten, es ist einfach nur alles gleich scheiße geblieben und nicht
scheißer geworden, hey.
Tja, vielleicht sollten wir uns mal bewerben für irgendwie,
oder nicht wir uns bewerben, sondern vielleicht könnt ihr vielleicht die Hörerinnen
und Hörer mal gute Nachrichten einwerfen, falls es welche gibt.
Könnt ihr uns drauf hinweisen?
Zum Beispiel auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen. Vielleicht sollten wir uns dazu mal noch kurz äußern.
Ah möchtest du über, ja kannst du dich gerne zu äußern.
Ich meine wir haben uns ja schon zu Social Media hier ganz viel geäußert so und naja ihr wisst ja,
das mit dem Facebook, das wird nichts mehr mit uns, das ist ja auch mittlerweile
glaube ich für alte Leute.
Was haben wir mit alten Leuten zu tun?
Instagram, benutzt du das?
Ich hab, ab und zu guck ich mal bei Instagram rein, ja.
Ich kann diese, also diesen Selbstdarstellungszoom kann ich immer nur wenige
Minuten am Stück ertragen.
Das ist schon sehr, ja das zeigt für mich einfach eine Welt wie sinnlich sein
soll, in der ich auch nicht leben will.
Und die Leute da mit ihren Storys und ihrem ganzen sich selber so geil finden,
das kann ich mir immer nur ein paar Minuten angucken.
Gibt aber ein paar Kanäle, da gibt ein paar Kanäle, wo die ganze Zeit so Luxusautos
zu Schrott gefahren werden.
Die finde ich lustig, also das kann ich, die stehen bei mir hoch im Kurs,
Irgendwelche Idioten, die da Fahrzeuge fahren, die sie nicht unter Kontrolle
haben und dann eben so eine viertel Millionen um den Baum wickeln,
weil sie irgendjemanden am Straßenrand beeindrucken wollten mit ihrem Auto.
Da kann ich zugeben, dass das interessiert mich und manchmal,
wenn Leute hinfallen, aber nur wenn die sich nicht richtig übel verletzen.
Da gibt's auch manchmal, wenn die dann so, weißt du, eben diese Parcours-Leute.
Die dann manchmal springen, die sehr ungünstig und das gucke ich nicht so gerne.
Die nicht an der richtigen Stelle hinspringen meinst du?
Auch an der richtigen Stelle ist, ja klar das ist hauptsächlich irgendwelche
Skater, die meinen sie müssten halt breitbahnig so ein Geländer runterrutschen mit ihrem Brett.
Wo sich auch irgendwie, wo du denkst Leute habt ihr kein Internet?
Das weiß man doch, dass das schief geht und man weiß auch ganz genau wie das
schief geht und man hat eine Vermutung wie weh das tut wenn das schief geht.
Warum macht ihr das?
Ja gut, also ich wäre den Leuten nicht die Möglichkeit nehmen sich sportlich
da zu betätigen und Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen,
die andere Leute schon tausendmal gewonnen haben, ja also das steht ja jedem frei,
aber man muss irgendwie nicht dran teilnehmen und ich bin ja auch,
ich glaube nicht, dass man mir vorwerfen kann nicht internetaffin zu sein.
Ja ich mach das jetzt ja immerhin schon seit, das muss ich mal nachdenken,
seit wann darf ich denn was darf ich denn behaupten wie lange ich jetzt internet
mache, ich würde mal sagen, sein heute morgen, nachweisbar, habe ich jetzt 35
Jahre, internet erfahrung.
Alter Schwede, das ist ganz schön viel.
Und es fing ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht schon damals mit Social Media an,
also bevor das richtige Internet da war, gab es so Usenet und so und das war
dann halt auch so Mail und Newsgroups und da fing man dann schon an sich auch
gegenseitig voreinander aufzuplustern und toller zu finden als andere und online
zu beschimpfen und so, das war ja alles schon immer da.
Ich hab das erfunden.
Also Flamewar, den Begriff kenne ich wirklich seit 35 Jahren.
Und heute hat das nochmal exorbitantere Formen angenommen und das haben wir
ja auch schon tausendmal besprochen. So jetzt natürlich die Frage,
wie kommuniziert man denn dann nun in der Öffentlichkeit?
Und ich will jetzt auch nicht behaupten, dass Social Media zu nix gut ist.
Ich war immer ein Twitterati, denke ich. Also mir hat das Prinzip von Twitter
an sich sehr zugesagt und es hat ja auch sehr lange sehr gut funktioniert.
Twitter ist natürlich jetzt dead. Also ich benutze das jetzt ausschließlich noch um ein paar,
eigentlich nur noch eine einzige Twitterliste zu lesen, was übrigens hinterhin
den Vorteil hat, dass man nicht in so einer algorithmischen Timeline gefangen
ist, sondern dass man sozusagen da wirklich mal noch alle Tweets sieht,
die in einem Kanal erscheinen.
Das ist sozusagen die Möglichkeit noch in irgendeiner Form Twitter überhaupt noch zu konsumieren.
Das ist halt einfach das alles über eine Liste zu machen und nicht über Followship sozusagen.
Und so kann ich dann zum Beispiel so meinen ukrainischen Newsflow noch irgendwie
genießen, ohne irgendwie von dem Rest überrannt zu werden.
Und trotzdem hat das halt alles keinen Sinn. So und jetzt natürlich die Frage
was setzt sich so als nächstes durch und man möchte natürlich gerne etwas haben
was so ähnlich funktioniert.
Da gibt's jetzt das Mastodon Netzwerk, da könnt ihr Logbuch Netzpolitik folgen.
LNP at Podcasts.social ist da quasi das Zauberwort oder sagt man at Podcasts.social at LNP?
LNP, podcast, social, oder so rum, ja genau, also wie auch immer.
Ja musst du mal machen, ist geil.
Da haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit und sind ansprechbar,
den ME-Netzpolitik-Account auf Twitter gibt's noch.
Ich lese den im Prinzip auch noch so ein bisschen mit, aber mangels guter Tools,
weil es jetzt noch diesen kranken Twitter-Client gibt, lässt sich das eigentlich
gar nicht mehr verwenden.
Also geht nicht davon aus, dass wir da was sehen, weil es einfach sein kann, dass wir das übersehen.
Aufpassen, dann geht das. Da muss man nochmal gucken, ob das mit Blue Sky noch was wird.
Das würde ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht ausschließen, aber das ist halt immer
noch ein geschlossenes Netzwerk.
Also das habe ich mir angeguckt, das ist ja wohl ein Witz, allein dieses Logo,
das kann doch keiner ernst meinen.
Wieso, was ist damit?
Dieses irgendwie völlig kaputt gesättigte Foto von einem Himmel,
das ist ja irgendwie Kadenabiablau.
Vielleicht ist es auch Röhnendorf, wer weiß.
Aber richtig falsch abgemischt, da steht auf jeden Fall Zukunft.
Meinst du da ist nicht genug Vitalität drin oder nicht genug Freiheit?
Also ne sorry, ich find das sieht überhaupt, also ist in Ordnung, sieht aus wie Twitter.
Und ob da auch irgendwie die libertären Hansel den Ton angeben oder ob das in
irgendeiner Form eine andere Governance findet, das muss sich noch zeigen.
Genauso ist ja auch die Zukunft von dieser ganzen Fettyverse-Wolke auch noch
nicht gesichert, wohin da die Reise geht. Also derzeit ist es einfach offen,
meiner Auffassung nach.
Anyway auf jeden Fall haben wir diesen Account.
Immerhin das ist ja auch mal, das ist ja potenziell auch mal ganz nett,
ist ja auch mal schön wenn man offen ist, wohin es geht und so aber ja.
Ja das, genau das finde ich eigentlich auch mal ganz angenehm so,
weil zumindest haben sich jetzt so die Platzhirschen alle ziemlich daneben benommen,
Und dann kam es ja hier Facebook wieder mit ihrem Threads,
was sie wieder ausgegraben haben, was in halbkürzester Zeit ganz viele User hat,
aber wo halt glaube ich auch nur irgendwelche gekauften Celebrities rumschreien und keine Ahnung,
also der Hype war dann auch relativ schnell wieder weg, vielleicht ignoriere
ich das einfach nur, aber ich werde auf gar keinen Fall in so ein Social Network
gehen, was Zuckerberg aufgebaut hat, das ist ja dann wirklich vom Regen in die Traufe.
Von daher, Mastodon funktioniert jetzt erstmal ganz gut,
vielleicht kommt Blue Sky nochmal dazu, ansonsten könnt ihr einfach uns weiterhin
in die Kommentare schreiben,
in unserem kleinen Blog, das funktioniert ganz wunderbar, da hat man irgendwie
alles für eine Sendung beisammen, das ist für uns auch sehr praktisch,
Weil wir dann eben vor einer Sendung nochmal in Ruhe da durchgehen können.
Also wir lesen das meistens schon wenn es auftaucht, aber dann hat man es ja
dann auch nochmal im Kontext mit den ganzen anderen Antworten.
So gucken wie man das in Zukunft vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen ausbauen kann.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine Art von Rückmeldung, die wir sehr gerne mögen.
Insbesondere wenn sie so inhaltlich dann auch noch weiteres hinzufügt und unser
Halbwissen entsprechend umgeht.
Ja es hat ja auch den Vorteil, es ist dann halt an der Sendung dran und also
ist ja schon mal ganz okay, wenn euer Feedback dann auch dauerhaft in dem Kontext
bleibt und nicht irgendwo durchrollt.
Richtig, genau. Das ist nicht auf irgendeiner vergänglichen Plattform,
die von irgendeinem verrückten Millionär kaputt gemacht wird.
Er kauft das Elon-Mask das die ganze Zeit. Genau.
Und da auf der Metaebene Webseite oder auf der Logbuch Netzpolitik Webseite
in dem Zusammenhang, da gibt's dann auch keine Cookies und nix gespeichert,
weil mich das alles nicht interessiert.
Ich frag mich immer, wenn ich auf so Webseiten komme, kommst du auf irgendeine
Webseite, weil es da irgendwas zu kaufen gibt, was dich vielleicht interessiert,
oder irgendwo gelesen hast, wo dir irgendeiner einen Tipp gegeben hat,
dann klickst du da drauf.
Und dann musst du dich erst mal 10 Minuten mit irgendwelchen aufpoppenden Bannern
so ja hier Cookie und lass mich doch bitte dich tracken und wir wollen es doch
alles wissen und ich so nein nein geht weg und dann muss man aber immer mal.
Die wollen es ja vor allem gar nicht, das wollen doch nur die scheiß Werbepenner
die ich von Anfang an auf die Seite geholt hab.
Einfach gar nicht erst klicken Tim, immer weiter scrollen, immer weiter swipen, left left left.
Ja und dann kommt doch der Banner runter und willst du Notifications haben,
nein ich will jetzt auch erstmal keine Notifikation, ich will erstmal nur drauf
schauen, damit ich überhaupt mal weiß, worum es geht und so,
ja aber hier unser Newsletter, willst du nicht unser Newsletter haben,
wir schicken dir auch immer alles und so, nein, Leute wirklich lasst mich doch
einfach mal in Frieden lesen.
Also ja, das Ende von Twitter, also ich finde das auch immer noch äußerst schade,
ja, weil der, es wurde jetzt vielleicht technisch nachempfunden,
aber so den Ort, den ich da jetzt irgendwie dann doch über zehn Jahre und länger hatte,
mit den Leuten, die ich mir da kuratiert hatte und den Inhalten,
den wird es halt so nicht mehr geben, das ist erstmal schade, ja. Ähm...
Gleichzeitig habe ich, ich twittere jetzt auch nur noch äußerst selten,
wahrscheinlich mache ich einfach irgendwas anderes mit der gewonnenen Zeit,
keine Ahnung was, aber, ja es ist traurig aber ich bin jetzt auch drüber weg, so.
Ja und ich bin ganz froh, dass es jetzt auch nicht mehr Twitter heißt.
Ja den Gefallen muss man dem Typen ja nicht tun, dass man den einfach umbenennen
lässt, also ich rede von Twitter, das was früher war, das gibt's ja jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja eben, deswegen bin ich ja ganz froh, dass er es unbedingt hat,
weil es jetzt klar ist, so scheiße heißt jetzt X und Twitter war halt früher so,
aber jetzt kann ich halt immer noch mein Twitter Gedenkbüchlein auf dem Klo
liegen haben mit irgendwie damals,
als die Tweets noch 140 Zeichen hatten und alle was lustiges geschrieben haben,
weil sie daran Interesse daran hatten irgendwie ihre Freude und ihre Begeisterung
über ein Netzwerk zu teilen,
wo tolle Leute sind, mit denen man super sich über lustige Sachen austauschen
kann und kreativ über Lösungen für unsere Zukunft unterhalten kann,
bis es halt auch wieder so eine Echo Chamber von Schreihälsen wurde,
die sich alle gegenseitig nur den Tod an Hals wünschen und generell einfach
offensichtlich gar kein Interesse daran haben, dass die Welt mal ein schönerer Platz wird.
Also das macht mich ja auch einfach, das finde ich auch immer so furchtbar an dem Ganzen.
Andererseits, ja, naja, also, was soll man noch dazu sagen.
Also mit anderen Worten, ich hab jetzt unsere Mastodon Links in die Show Notes
gemacht, also podcast.social,
slash at LNP, chaos.social slash at Linuzifer und mastodon.social.
Willst du selber sagen? Es ist ein bisschen schwierig auszusprechen.
Das ist echt ein Problem von Mastodon.
Mit diesen ganzen Ad-hosts und so weiter. Das ist krank. Das ist bei Blue Sky
wirklich besser gelöst.
Wie auch immer, ich bin auf Mastodon Social, Ad Tim Pridlaff und Ad Meda Ebene
und werde auf Podcast Social oder habe auf Podcast Social auch für meinen ganzen anderen Podcast,
falls ihr die hört, auch die entsprechenden Accounts, also Ad Raumzeit, Ad UKW, etc.
Pp. Und ja, mal gucken, auf bluesky bin ich auch, Tim Pridlaff.
Könnte ich auch add Linuzifar, aber das kann ich jetzt noch nicht mal finden,
da kann man noch nicht mal linken, oder?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich gerade gar nicht.
Ist egal, das ist ja auch noch closed, das ist ja noch mit invite codes und baut sich langsam auf.
Ich denke, da können wir nochmal drauf eingehen, sollte das nochmal a Thing werden.
Aber schön finde ich, dass man da mit seiner eigenen Domain sich einen Account
machen kann. Also da bin ich dann halt at tim.brittler.org und at metaebene.me, weil geht halt.
Habe ich noch nicht rausgefunden, wie man da sagen kann, welche Notifications
man haben möchte und welche nicht.
Die App sieht für mich wirklich aus wie ein Studentenprojekt,
wo man echt nochmal drüber nachdenken sollte, ob man das jetzt als bestanden wäre.
Wenn du mit der App nicht glücklich bist, dann nimm einfach Ivory.
Es gibt eine Bridge, Ivory ist auch totaler Wurstquatsch ey,
das ist ein komplett kaputtes Interface, Ice Cubes ist das einzige was ich irgendwie ernst nehmen kann.
Wie auch immer, du kannst auf jeden Fall dein Blue Sky Account auch über eine
Macedon Bridge, über skybridge.fly.dev.
Jaja, das ist halt, warum nicht. Funktioniert zumindest. Also ich hab einen
Account für beide Netzwerke. Also ich hab eine App für beide Netzwerke.
Okay, immerhin. Wie heißt das?
Skybridge.fly.dev.
Ah klar, natürlich.
Und da kannst du halt, naja, Moment und wer ist fly.dev? Fly ist so ein Hoster
und Skybridge ist halt so ein Projekt.
Hat der irgendwas mit, also kriegt der jetzt irgendwie meine Blue Sky Daten, wenn ich die da eingebe?
Ja, du, ja, ich kann dir das jetzt nicht erklären.
Bring your favorite message.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du darüber deinen Account sozusagen wie einen Mastodon
Account erscheinen lassen, sodass du einen Mastodon Client benutzen kannst,
um auch BlueSky zu benutzen.
Das ist immer schon sehr technisch. Das ist ja eigentlich eher was für die Freak
Show. Die ist morgen dran.
Ja, der hat auch diesen komplett übersteuerten Himmel.
Ne da gebe ich erstmal meine Daten nicht ein.
Das ist Kabanabia blau ist das.
Das ist Kabanabia, so ist der Himmel über Kabanabia,
aber nur wenn in, ja was ist jetzt eigentlich das türkise da von den beiden
ist es jetzt irgendwie in Bad Henef,
ich hab leider auch das Video öfter geguckt ich kann jetzt auch nicht genau
sagen welche von den beiden Farmen welche ist.
Weißt du noch wofür die stehen?
Freiheit und Vitalität und irgendwas.
Wir stehen auch für Freiheit und Vitalität.
Heute ich ganz besonders, bei mir merkt man heute die Freiheit und die Vitalität,
die wir aus allen Poren getrofft haben,
hier der Kadenavia Blau, so Leute, jetzt haben wir genug gequatscht,
wir entlassen euch, bis nächstes mal, tschüss, ciao, ciao.